hey 42 here looking around at the world
today it's hard to imagine another time
when there was so much human conflict
all over the media we're met with a
seemingly constant flow of wars uprising
and politicians making violent threats
then of course there's the internet a
place with more trolls than middle earth
and where the average twitter feed reads
like a scene from the exorcist
it all seems to suggest that both
individually and collectively we as a
species are getting angrier which is why
you might be surprised to hear that some
scholars consider the last three decades
to have been the most peaceful in human
history
don't get me wrong i'm not saying
there's no fighting obviously even in
2003 at the height of this recent
peaceful period there were more than 30
wars going on around the globe
it's just that our history as a species
is riddled with them in fact over the
last 3 400 years mankind has lived
relatively harmoniously
for just
268 orbits around the sun basically only
eight percent of recorded history has
been free of major hostilities
there are prisons with better statistics
than that
beyond the obvious destruction and
brutality of the conflict itself
war is full of horrors like the nazi
concentration camps of world war ii
but war is also full of stories that
reveal the better qualities of humankind
stories such as this one about a man who
risked everything
by volunteering
to be sent to auschwitz
if you love travelling like i do then
you'll love the fastest and easiest vpn
surf shark did you know surf shark helps
you to avoid price discrimination based
on your location so you can save money
on plane tickets and car rentals whilst
travelling surfshock runs on any device
anywhere and it's packed full of
features
such as industry-leading uncrackable
encryption ip and dns leak protection an
internet kill switch if your vpn drops
out and 24 7 customer support personally
i use surfshark to watch netflix content
from other countries such as the us
that's usually blocked here in the uk
it's really easy all you have to do is
switch over your location settings and
there you have it access to all your
favorite programs and servchack
maintains a strict no logs policy their
network of 3200 servers in over 95
countries runs completely on ramp so
they couldn't like your data even if
they wanted to by using the code 42
you'll benefit from an 83 discount plus
three extra mums for free all you have
to do is click the special link in the
description below don't miss out and
thank you to surfshark for sponsoring
this video
before it became the most infamous death
camp of the biggest war in history
auschwitz which is located in poland was
a detention camp for minority groups and
poles who'd committed the heinous crime
of owning land the nazis wanted
since poland's occupiers were fond of
mass arrests there weren't enough spaces
in existing jails to house the rapidly
growing number of prisoners so camps
like auschwitz were established
the first train carrying 728 polish
prisoners to the notorious facility
arrived in june 1940
within a few weeks relatives of those
who'd been in turn started to receive
telegrams informing them of their loved
ones deaths
this terrible turn of events quickly
came to the attention of the underground
polish resistance who decided to
investigate
enter
whittled pilecki
who may be one of the most notable
heroes you've never heard of
don't worry you're not alone even in his
native poland it was only in the 1990s
after the fall of communism in poland
that he was first publicly recognised
for his remarkable achievements during
world war ii
like his comrades in the resistance
pilecki was intent on discovering what
was going on behind those auschwitz
fences
but unlike his brothers and sisters in
arms he decided the best way to do that
was to be arrested and sent to the camp
from there he would be able to report on
conditions and organize a prisoner
movement to fight back against the nazis
of course he would also be trapped in a
place dedicated to brutality and death
but that clearly wasn't a significant
enough deterrent to make him change his
mind
world war ii kicked off with germany's
invasion of poland on the 1st of
september 1939
and poland's defense was spirited but
short-lived in fact the country never
officially surrendered but after soviet
forces invaded from the east on the 17th
of september the battle was clearly lost
pilecki was ordered to flee his native
country but instead he remains there to
continue the underground fight against
the invaders
he was responsible for jointly founding
one of the first resistance movements
the secret polish army which was well
polish
and a secret
at its height the organization had close
to 20 000 members and it was eventually
absorbed into the polish home army
a colossal underground network of
freedom fighters who had no intention of
accepting the rule of their new
occupiers on the 19th of september 1940
using fake identity documents polesky
allowed himself to be rounded up and
arrested by the nazis
that was the easy part in those days all
you needed to get yourself arrested was
a face
the hard part was still to come and soon
enough polesky was sent to auschwitz
where he became prisoner 4859
it's hard to imagine what was going
through the man's mind when the train
first arrived at the camp no doubt he'd
been expecting conditions to be bad but
auschwitz was still relatively new at
the time and details on what really went
on in the camp were scanned
deliberately getting himself arrested
was undeniably an incredibly brave thing
to do
but in truth polesky would have no idea
of the sheer horrors that awaited him in
his new life
not that it took long for him to get a
taste he and his fellow prisoners were
beaten with clubs the moment they
stepped down from the train
then their heads were shaved and they
were systematically robbed of any
possessions they'd managed to bring with
them
at one point ten men were separated from
the group seemingly at random and
executed on the spot for no apparent
reason
polesky didn't know it then
but he would spend the next two and a
half years of his life in conditions
that most of us would have a hard time
even imagining
let alone enduring
he managed to get the first of his many
reports out of the camp and back to home
army hq not long after his arrival
many more would follow usually smuggled
out by the few people lucky enough to
somehow escape from auschwitz with their
lives
even a hardened fighting man like
polesky was shocked by what he
encountered at the camp horrific abuses
from the outset of the facility's
operation prisoners endured grim
punishments starvation and the constant
threat of death pileski himself was in
no way cushioned from the harsh
realities of auschwitz and he was fought
into slave labor along with his fellow
prisoners like those men and women he
suffered unimaginable hardship the work
was back-breaking the rations were
deliberately pitiful and disease ravaged
to camp on a near-constant basis polesky
himself battled with at least three
life-threatening bouts of illness
including pneumonia
considering what he was going through
you could easily forgive puleski for
forgetting about his mission altogether
to dedicate all his attention to trying
to survive
but this man was made of stern stuff
and showing incredible courage he formed
a prisoner's resistance movement known
as the zow the organization was designed
to improve morale amongst the prisoners
by sourcing extra food clothing and even
medical supplies
at the same time polesky set up
intelligence networks to collect useful
information and send it to those on the
outside
the group was organized in such a way
that no senior member knew the identity
of his peers meaning that should anyone
be caught they would be physically
unable to give up their comrades no
matter what unspeakable torture they
were subjected to
under poleski's leadership the group
united and absorbed all other resistance
movements in auschwitz eventually
growing to include over 1 000 members
from the many different areas of the
camp
during polesky's imprisonment he would
become the principal source of
information about the camp and chief
witness to the changes it would undergo
his reports were sent to the home army
and from there on to the exiled polish
government in london and senior figures
amongst the allies
poleski's accounts detailed the
atrocities being committed at the camp
the mass exterminations the starvation
the casual brutality of the guards and
the twisted experiments that were being
carried out on auschwitz inmates
he also did his best to provide cold
hard figures the total number of
prisoners the frequency and volume of
new arrivals and his best approximation
of the number of deaths
a figure that would eventually top one
million souls
the allied powers initially believed
these reports were being somehow
exaggerated
what happened at auschwitz was quite
literally unbelievable
but the reports kept on coming and the
atrocities they depicted only continue
to grow both in scale and depravity
polesky hoped the intelligence he was
gathering would lead to some kind of
liberation or support for his fellow
prisoners
but as we now know that wasn't to be
[Music]
the zow continued to grow until the
spring of 1942.
but by the autumn of the same year the
gestapo had managed to root out and kill
many of its members
some close colleagues of poleshki's were
arrested and camp authorities made the
decision to transfer older polish
prisoners to camps in germany so as to
further disrupt the resistance group
pileski knew this could only end badly
and he believed he'd be able to convince
the home army to mount a rescue
operation if only he could speak to his
superiors in person
of course there was only one way to do
that
he was going to have to escape from
auschwitz
prisoners at the camp were beaten
humiliated and very often executed even
for minor infractions and often for no
reason at all being caught attempting to
escape was quite simply a death sentence
but if he wanted to help his fellow
prisoners pileski had no choice but to
try
so
one april night in 1943 he and two of
his fellow prisoners pried open a metal
door at the bakery where they were
working the night shift
despite their weakened states they were
able to subdue a guard before locking
him in a woodshed
they also had the presence of mind to
sever a phone line and disable an alarm
before escaping on foot taking stolen
german identity documents with them
it would be several days almost 100
kilometers and at least one close call
with german soldiers during which
poleski was shot and wounded before the
men reached the security of a home army
safe house
outside occupied warsaw
there pileski started work on what's now
known as withhold report which focused
on the zow and his experiences in
auschwitz the purpose of the report was
to convince the home army to attempt to
liberate the camp
but
the organization concluded that even if
they were to attack auschwitz they
didn't have the resources to transport
the prisoners to safety despite the
setback pileski continued to fight for
both the resistance and for his former
inmates in auschwitz coordinating
activities between the zow and the home
army as best as he could
by february 1944 he was promoted to the
rank of captain and in the summer of the
following year he took part in the
warsaw uprising during which the home
army attempted to oust the occupying
germans
pileski was actually supposed to remain
out of harm's way during the uprising
but true to form he entered the conflict
anonymously and fought as a regular
soldier unsurprisingly he excelled and
as polish casualties began to mount he
revealed his true identity and rank to
his superior officers who immediately
put him in command of his own unit
after 63 days of brutal fighting the
warsaw uprising ended in failure and
polesky was one of the many poles forced
to surrender to the nazis
he was taken to a pow camp in bavaria
where he would spend the rest of the war
until the camp's liberation in april
1945
but whilst the second world war came to
an end for most people in 1945
things were a little different in poland
red army soldiers still occupied the
country and stalin orchestrated the
installation of a soviet-backed puppet
government that transformed poland into
little more than a vassal state of the
soviet union
after a brief stint in italy poleski was
ordered to go undercover in his native
country to gather intelligence on the
activities of the occupying soviets
arriving in warsaw in december 1945 he
recruited members from the zow and the
home army to form a new intelligence
network though it was probably a walk in
the park compared to auschwitz pileski's
time undercover was still incredibly
dangerous and he was forced to change
identities and jobs on a regular basis
in order to avoid discovery
those precautions worked for a while but
in 1946 he received a tip-off that his
cover had been compromised he was
ordered to pull out of poland
immediately
but he refused to abandon his homeland
polesky was arrested by the soviets on
the 8th of may 1947.
he was interrogated and tortured for
upwards of a year by men who were well
known for their cruelty
but
he never talked
[Music]
when it became clear he wasn't going to
give up any valuable information on the
polish resistance poleski was put on
trial where he was accused of a battery
of charges against a puppet state
including illegal border crossing the
use of forged documents espionage and
planning to assassinate several senior
politicians
he pleaded guilty to all but two of the
charges he denied espionage on the
grounds that he was an officer of the
second polish corps and therefore wasn't
breaking any laws and he denied the
charge of planning assassinations for
the simple reason that they weren't true
not that any of it mattered the trial
was a sham and there is only going to
ever be one outcome
polesky was found guilty on all counts
he was executed on the 25th of may 1948.
to this day nobody knows where his body
is buried
[Music]
until 1989 captain pileski's remarkable
story was censored in poland
but after the collapse of communism his
trial was officially reviewed and the
sentence quashed
in 1995 he was posthumously awarded the
order of polonia restitutor and in 2006
the order of the white eagle the highest
decoration in all of poland
these medals probably wouldn't have
meant much to a man who had fought so
bravely for his country's liberty
but still
it does feel like justice was eventually
served
[Music]
thanks for watching